vous faites un métier un petit peu
spéciale puisque vous est ce qu'on
appelle une rigologue alors qu'est ce
que la rigologie et commence assez matic
alors la rigologie oui qu'est-ce que
c'est ce soit intrigant s'agit-il alors
oui la rigologie en fait c'est tout
simplement une technique de
développement personnel c'est une
technique tout simplement pour s'apaiser
pour prendre soin de soi pour cultiver
sa joie son bonheur et pour adopter une
attitude positive envers la vie titre
que certains font de la sophrologie ou
la méditation voilà tout à fait via la
rigologie à la rigologie donc ces
espèces en atelier donc l'utiliser
vertus du rire du jeu et de l'amusement
donc c'est une technique est assez
récente qui a eu un peu plus d'une
quinzaine d'années qui a été créé par
une française qui s'appelle corinne
cosseron dont qui a créé également
l'école internationale du rire et du
bonheur c'est là où j'ai été formé pour
être donc rideau d'actu pas où je vais à
l'école desquels l'école du rire et aux
chandelles à l'envi les formidables un
peu ses limites
c'est de la télé en fait c'est l'école
du rire et du monarque et ça se pratique
comment te dire on vient on pratique
comme vous pratiquez un sport où on
vient pour une heure oui alors en
général dix ans les 6es dure une heure
donc ces espèces on commence par un
échauffement corporel ou connaissent pas
tout de suite en dans le reer ya une
technique dont on craint alors on
commence par un échauffement ou 7,6
roubaïe on évacue les tensions respire
bien rigolé faut bien rire il faut bien
respirer pardon quoi et puis ensuite
c'est un enchaînement d'exercices de je
lui dis deux minimes
voilà et on termine par la méditation du
rire c'est à dire qu on s'allonge au sol
et on laisse librement sortie en nourrir
voilà et puis on fait un petit
relaxation pour un retour au calme
d'accord d'accord travers alors je mets
moi ils ont évidemment énormément de
questions à vous poser est ce lui il
élude ronde ont le don dont le rire et
la passion jimmy mohamed ne vous moquez
pas moi je ris beaucoup extérieur
j'aurai beaucoup et d'ailleurs est ce
qu'on peut pratiquer la rigologie seul
et même lorsqu'on a un pouvoir comique
assez faibles ou inexistants comme
caroline où l'usiné
[Applaudissements]
j'espère sur la question si par exemple
on peut être on peut être un petit peu
timide par exemple on a envie de le
faire chez soi à la maison est ce que
une pop on peut alors l'arrière que
trois exercices la rigologie seul nom
c'est un petit peu compliqué par contre
on peut rire tout seul chez soi oui ça
c'est possible mais la rigologie c'est
vrai que c'est plus autour d'un
animateur et avec d'autres personnes
puisque on fait des jeux donc pour faire
un jeu il faut y aller a fait l'exercice
comme on pourrait méditer seul à la
maison il n'ya pas d'exercer ce que l'on
peut pratiquer salle alors on peut
s'amuser à rire tout seul mais c'est
plus dur rires en fait ça peut pas
appeler ça vraiment de la rigologie
voilà d'accord donc vous vous dites vous
fait un distinguo entre le rire que l'on
peut avoir à la maison seul lorsque je
fais des blagues
voilà par exemple black d'hilarantes des
diagonales et la rigologie qui est
vraiment une thérapie ces thérapies oui
alors si on peut on peut stimuler
sourire provoqué son rire et là on est
dans du yoga du rire par exemple vous
connaissez ample et aux aguets tuerie à
l'emploi - donne de quoi faire écrire
c'est un mois pour moi un yoga
al'inverse à ceux pratiqués dans une
sorte de silence presque religieux et on
était dans un état presque méditatif
donc yoga du rire ses impressions c'est
alors ça n'a rien à voir en fait du yoga
du rire ne vous attendez pas faire des
postures n'a rien à voir en fait c'est
un médecin indien le docteur madan
kataria qui a inventé ce concept en 1995
donc c'est le concept du rire sans
raison en fait il s'est rendu qu'à base
ils le font tous les rangs du compte en
fait lors d'études queue basse et
passion les patients qui criait beaucoup
mairie c'est beaucoup plus vite en fait
est que un reer simuler autant de
pouvoir career naturel voilà donc le
premier atelier enfin les premières
séances de yoga du rire ou au gabon bail
en 1995 dans les parcs y rassembler des
gens ils se sont mis à rire comme ça
voilà hees avait justement statue divine
sur le sourire entre guillemets stimuler
ou forcé c'est ça une question là dessus
c'était précisément ma question parce
que j'ai vachement sceptiques
comment est-ce qu'un rire forcé donc un
rire un peu faux peut avoir les mêmes
vertus sur notre corps sur la santé kari
en francs est vrai voilà tu fais tout le
temps
arrête toi non alors tu raconte des
blagues l'enduro
alors c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on dit
dans les études en tout cas moi je ne
peux pas vous l'expliquer je suis pas
médecin je vais avoir du mal à vous
l'expliquer mais c'est vraiment dans les
études ce qu'on dit que ça autant
pouvoir à rire simuler qu'un reer
naturel on a les mêmes avantages
physiologiques et psychologiques
quels sont les avantages justement
physiologique et psychologues alors
rires donc le rire est vraiment
excellent pour la santé c'est un anti
stress
regardez moi ma vie il faut dire que
quand aurait en fait on va sécréter tout
un cocktail de bonne hormone dont les
endorphines lemon du bien-être les
hormones du bonheur mais pas que
l'ocytocine l'ado camilla certains quand
on rit on booth notre système
immunitaire avec la production
d'anticorps aussi contre caen le rire et
j'allais lancer franc fort ces bruits
hockey pee wee qui a tous les bienfaits
qui se met en place on s'est créé toutes
ces hormones tout à fait donc ça ça
fortifie le muscle cardiaque ça facilite
la digestion s'améliore la qualité du
sommeil
alors voilà il y est j'ai envie de dire
également une question dit en parlant
des vertus justement moi j'ai lu
bizarrement que le rire avait des vertus
incroyable sur la sexualité un peu
compliqué mais fait jaser mois fait dans
un magazine féminin de bien sûr que sar
boost est comme ça l'énergie sexuelle et
la libido est ce que c'est vrai alors
moi je peux pas me vous le confirmer
mais je sais pas si j'ai que j'aborde
oui pardon mais carey carey des mois de
l'égyptien non mais j'imagine mais
j'imagine que c'est pas le moment de se
fendre la poire quant à nez avec son
compagnon aux mondiaux voilà elle alors
et la daïra de rire parfois par aviva en
fait à décrire le raz de sein et à
défaut si on fait plus on rit plus on a
envie de rire
et quand ricoune et souriant déjà ans
attire des gens positifs y ait une
réciprocité qui s'installe auront plus
facilement des gens et une ouverture
d'esprit et comme on s'est créé tout un
beau coup d'hormones qui et procure un
sentiment de bien-être
on est plus détendue et forcément moi je
suis convaincu les vertus du rire
vraiment convaincu merci infiniment qui
a fait une merci d'écouter
vous voulez tout l'information avec un
tube rendez-vous de 4 h 15 août les
actes menés 2-4
quand même fait c'est sa valeur merci
beaucoup merci merci
[Applaudissements]